so often
i'll take a fitness class or i'll go to
a music venue
or really anywhere that plays music in
the background
and i'll find myself loving the rhythms
and the melodies and the beats
and then i take a second to listen to
the lyrics lyrics that
for example place us in a position of
subservience that we would never
tolerate in any other context and i am
aghast at the degree to which we
normalize sexism in our culture
i listen to this music and i'm like i
don't want to have to turn up to the
sound of my own oppression
you know music is one of the most
powerful forms of communication because
it has the potential to either uplift
or oppress music caters to the emotions
music haters to the soul
music opens up our soul it opens up our
channels to receive information about
somebody else's walk of life to inform
our own roles
and while i have no problem with male
fantasy
what i do have a problem with is that
according to a recent study
only 2.6 of all music producers identify
as women
that means an even smaller percentage
identify as trans or gender
non-conforming
and why does this matter because if we
don't own and control our own narrative
somebody else will tell our stories for
us
and they will get it wrong perpetuating
the very myths
that hold us back and i'm not here to
tell other people
how to make their music but i am here to
provide
and design the alternative one strategy
i take in my music
is making uplifting energetic percussive
global beats and placing lyrics on top
of them that genuinely
describe my life's experiences without
contributing to the oppression of
anybody
else it's funny because it's the same
reason as to why we excuse
so many problematic lyrics it's because
we love how the beats make us feel
an example of this is my song top not
[Music]
turnip
[Music]
i turned off my phone's notifications so
i have more time
no bubbles too trouble my clear state of
mind one thing to know i'm not here to
please hair tied up i do it properly
my time is not your property when i'm
productive like my
ovaries ay give a grown girl room to
breathe basic rights in her liberty
free from insecurity that the world's
projecting onto me
please do not trouble me when i am
focused the future is female you already
know this i'm fighting against the
corruption let's go this turned up in my
top-notch since when i first wrote this
[Music]
i want us to keep making sex positive
beautiful music
about joy and freedom i want us to
embrace our own pleasure just as much as
we embrace our own pain
i want us to celebrate the authentic
nuanced
multi-dimensional aspects of our human
existence
rather than perform false narratives
of degrading sexuality in order to feel
accepted or loved
and another strategy that i take in my
music to combat the misogyny that exists
on the airwaves
is to visually depict the very world i
wish we lived in
in the music video for my song see me
through which is like a
vibey queer electronic r b song
i cast two of my dear friends anya and
dija
to play the role of the lovers because
they're married in real life
but what you don't know is that they
also are behind the camera
concepting and directing the entire
video
[Music]
music should be safe and accessible for
all to experience
as you can see it's not about losing the
sex appeal or swag that music has
it's about writing messages that infuse
tenderness and positivity
into music that motivates us and
challenges us
and while we as musicians absolutely
have the responsibility
to make music that isn't disempowering
the consumers can be part of the change
too
firstly we get to choose which songs we
want to mute and which songs we want to
turn louder
we get to say i respect myself enough to
say i don't want to listen to this and i
don't want this to be in anybody else's
space either
secondly we can simply ask ourselves
does this music or this message
contribute to the oppression of somebody
else
why am i tolerating it and finally we
can all be choosing to make playlists
or djing music that provides the right
vibe or mood that we're looking for in
that moment
without the problematic messaging why
does this matter
because it's teaching algorithms in our
streaming systems in our world
exactly what it is that we do want to
listen to
creating long-term change and a
feedbacking mechanism that
impacts the entire industry this is not
a message
for just a small group of people this is
a message that affects
everybody because when we protect and
liberate
our most vulnerable genders we liberate
everybody